state of wisconsin versus kyle written
house that's the first count of the
information joseph rosenbaum we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the second count of the
information richard mcginnis we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the third count of the information
unknown mail we the jury find the
defendant kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
as to the fourth count of the
information anthony huber we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fifth count of the information
gage rosecroits we the jury find the
defendant kyle edward kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
members of the jury are these your
unanimous verdicts
is there anyone who does not agree with
the verdicts as read
would you wish the
let's cross now live to our us
correspondent mark stone who was in the
courtroom for those verdicts uh mark
very emotional scenes there
yes an extraordinary moment a moment of
um
of legal history i would say that i
think will be used as a president in
times to come carl rittenhouse 18 years
old just 17
at the time the shootings took place
here in kenosha wisconsin last august
acquitted on all charges uh in court as
the charges were were read out um or as
the verdicts were read out i should say
uh he he cried
and collapsed the jurors themselves were
stoic uh stood there uh emotionless as
um the foreman read out the verdicts and
of course the families of those three
men to be shot one or two of them killed
the third injured
they were in court too held their hands
and they cried this is an extraordinary
case that has gripped america uh the
american news networks have been camped
outside this courtroom in kenosha uh in
the bitterly cold weather for the past
two weeks covering every twist and turn
of a trial that i think really goes to
the heart of of bitter divides across
the united states at the moment and
two very different portraits of carl
rittenhouse were presented
in court to the jury over the course of
the two-week trial either this was a man
who had come to this city had crossed
state lines from neighboring illinois a
city he knew well because his father had
lived here he'd come here in order to
protect the city to act as a as a
as an uplift upholding the um uh his
citizenship and uh protecting the city
from looters and vandals
and that he was offering medical help
that was one portrayal of him or
he was a man bent on violence who had as
we know turned up in the city uh with a
semi-automatic weapon and that he
instigated the actions which then
followed those very two different
accounts of the man and the jurors
believed
that he
acted in self-defense that he was
threatened by the three people
who he would shoot two of them as they
say died one was injured
that was the account that the jury
believed and therefore he has been
acquitted on all charges despite
shooting dead two men and wounding
a third the background of course
to all of this
was the shooting by police of jacob
blake in this city in august last year
that came at a high at a time of very
very high tension across the country
because of a number of police shootings
of black people across the country the
shooting of jacob blake
prompted widespread protests in this
city the black lives matter movement was
very active over the course of several
days and other movements as well in the
city and kyle rittenhouse had turned up
here in order to protect the city
he was then chased
by one man who was unarmed and in the
course of of that event carl rittenhouse
turned around and shot that man and
killed him uh he was then uh chased by a
second man who had was armed with with a
skateboard who hit him with the
skateboard he shot him too and he killed
him and a third man who was shot and
injured as well but uh the news this
afternoon in kenosha wisconsin is that
he has been acquitted on all charges
mark stone live in kenosha for us thank
you